my name is pierre de paz then welcome
back to fear amnesia a custom story
before i started i wanted to talk about
the heartbeat sensor like anyway i have
like a nipple nipples
i have a heartbeat sensor there a lot of
people who were curious about what the
[ __ ] was going on pretty cool I'm glad
you bros enjoyed it the only tip that I
got from you bros was to not look at it
the only reason why I wanted to do that
was to make sure that it was actually
working this is and I tried it one time
before with another scary game it didn't
really work out well nevertheless let's
emerge yourself when some amnesia
especially in the loading screen is that
making my our debate pump you and me in
the loading screens makes me nervous
does it make you nervous oh I bet it
does being here with such a it's
beautiful chiming lad that's myself you
know what I'm talking about don't you
okay
come on you can do it a lot of you bros
were saying that let's go outside again
actually that when you get scared your
heart beats harder but it might actually
be slower so it's not perfect this
module or whatever I can't go here
but it's enough to make you nervous and
you can tell you could tell it was
working a lot of times like it's not
working perfectly but good enough for me
right now I just don't know where the
[ __ ] to go like where is that [ __ ]
bucket whoa what is that [ __ ] creepy
man can I go here or what
Pizza scared and scared don't worry
we're fine we're fine
what's up here now again lapa all right
Oh what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh that
[ __ ] monster again what is that what
is this a crowbar what do I need with
this I know where I can use it or oil
that's my [ __ ] birthday dress
all right
we're fine we're [ __ ] fine nah deny
deny deny deny deny deny deny the
tinderbox big-ass party [ __ ] I love
big party [ __ ] a lot big party where
is this Oh
did she say don't follow me or did she
say follow me let me light a candle for
you
hello I doubt it am I supposed to am I
supposed to follow you
Wow let's not follow her let's use the
crowbar here maybe that'll work
oh maybe I can free it with a hammer
of course Wow holy [ __ ] let's do that
again
this one girl search for Jamie Oliver
one last hard blow for Lady
[ __ ] car the habit is useless
now but I still got the crowbar and the
planks are still here
are you serious sorry
ah ouch we go whoa we're going outside I
don't know what I feel about this prize
let me let a candle for you
there's nothing there we're fine
okay a small steel saw it's misspelled
but I forgive them what happens if we
jump down here I can't do it
whoa whoa whoa the Amos is [ __ ]
terrifying man all right we got a saw
for steel what where did we have steel
as a problem I don't even know do you
bros know please tell me because I don't
[ __ ] know perhaps a bird that died
and then whatever they may be up here I
don't know I haven't a know how you died
what's up this you suck shut up potato
what if we use it here no [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of luck
all right what if for years that [ __ ]
I'm out of luck oil I don't know what to
use it very confusing it may seem like
pills cheated bet kids did not cheat
whatsoever so I prize I see you bros
know I don't cheat when I play custom
stories because they are never like
impossible some stuff to find like I
mean it's common sense that if you go
into a room you check the shirt and you
click on it and you find the key in the
show I mean that's pretty obvious stuff
I don't need to [ __ ] to figure that
sorta thing out nope pills it's just
I'm sorry I cheated all right I'm sorry
what do you want buddy I'm just kidding
you look really nice today so it's okay
that I cheat ah whoa wah wah wah all
right we're going in here we are going
into the unknown where there are hands
it's dark more sharks oh no nightmare
don't try to patronize me you [ __ ]
boxes I didn't know you were nimble I
saw this [ __ ] you did there whoa I know
Oh what the [ __ ] well I'm just gonna am
I what's going on here did she say I
should find her or not bread potatoes oh
it's so dark I can't see anything oh oh
instead of teleporting naked guys it's
teleported women with clothes on shut
even wise even rice alright we're going
down here this okay we're following out
it reminds me a little bit of nightmare
house with a girl and oh thank god
thank Jesus thank you Jesus I love you
alright is that you Jesus where's my
lantern it's not working yes that
doesn't mine oh there's a leopard hiding
here good thing I saw you you little
[ __ ] alright she's telling me to hurry
but I'm not quite convinced yet
what the [ __ ] what's going on now we
spent some time together you and me
banked I see you're on your period well
they're not the key for me I'll just
take this bucket now and you don't do
anything
let me just poke him to make sure that
is another line bah bah
you always poke them nipples lies dead
is dead as a [ __ ]
all righty then
we had the bucket the door is locked
while I have this key all right so okay
we're here now cool
that doesn't even make sense isn't that
where we came from well we have the
bucket now and we can do fun stuff
oh yes serious all right now I know it's
a bit confusing honestly hello mr.
sherry here jump down shame bit sorry
ain't no time no time for that today we
are just gonna try to save the day with
mcpixel
actually it's not Mac pixel [ __ ] you
gotta walk a lot in this case I'm sorry
I don't makes me connect with your
breath so that's good how are you today
yes very interesting Oh your mom did
what oh sorry your mom wasn't involved I
misheard mom with something else what
what do you mean no object to use is on
what do you mean there we go
what is that my dick my arm it looks
strange
what what what what Saturday am i
turning into one of those sexy beasts I
looked a bit funny but hey it's kind of
cool
who closed that door okay we're going
down we're gonna take the water and then
we're gonna party I don't really like
going down here
where's the fire I know for sure that
was a fire here that it is okay thought
it was strange this should not be enough
but hey I'll take it
all right a big ahh bra's you're coming
with me [ __ ] right where did it
go
what are you doing dance what the hell
did you know whoa
you crazy [ __ ] pants yukata God then
Mikkel shuttle barrel
oh you're going up day oh that's right
pablor
whoa where am I oh okay rub a rope with
a magnet come on
why do I need that why is there well or
something I don't remember seeing a
while maybe over here No
Wow
while the kids decide about this
all right we are here at the machine
room this is where we're supposed to be
there we go boom shacka Mack a smack of
Brackett bro there we go good the steam
is off now hell hey I'm hurrying I'm a
little nervous now actually I don't know
I don't know about this press alright
we're going down here no well we go in
here oh [ __ ]
chief or the front door whoa shut up
nah god damn it well good thing I got
this [ __ ] ah Joe that was a good one
why does with my hand it looks like a
nothing all right I got the key back now
I'm out of here
oh that's right I'm outta here [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] ghosts man I'm
not down with it
no I'm not no I'm not I'm not down to
[ __ ] it down when I've brown with your
brown ass socks you're wearing brown
socks do you really think that's a
suitable color to wear sock well fine
then I'm not the one who judged up socks
where the hell do I go back why the [ __ ]
are we there we are all right [ __ ] man
[ __ ] it's kind of interesting to see how
that affected me anyway we're going back
I think I know where this is so don't
worry about it go
I deserve that [ __ ] doesn't follow me
Oh fitta
she is probably we are most likely
[ __ ] if I know her then I know they we
are [ __ ]
well baby it's just so vain you know
maybe this has a happy ending after all
I don't think so is it here no of course
not that would have been too easy let me
get some a saw hello so how are ya I
love pets I didn't know I could talk
before well you can now your dreams at
yeah but my dreams are actually because
I'm a [ __ ] oh I'm sorry
get out of here then map head jaysis
yeah here it is okay but by gosh
[ __ ]
what oh I need this song alright oh [ __ ]
they don't like that hey Jerri
I missed ya what is going on here
what
[Music]
did she kill herself
is that what the balcony fell okay she
she likes to jump from Alka nice that's
okay with me I mean if no we're back
here no no I don't want to be here I
want to go home mom well you know what I
can do that too
don't think you're cool for doing that
[ __ ] I can't do that she is cool for
doing that
well I'm trapped here now but I can't go
back here all right but I guess I'll
just go home I guess I just go home to
my mom I have some pizza slice when my
mama because my mama is awesome
we have pizza slices together did you
want a pizza slice to carry on my
wayward son that will be P when they
come when the breast come lay your weary
head to rest fine so fine oh yeah wrap
bambo bell I guess that's it bet i
mighta but I bow to the [ __ ] key
doesn't work oh it's working all right
all right it was a funny shirt
I'm Nisha cousin sorry it was fun
I liked that it was a little maybe a
little parsley but I still enjoyed it I
had
one really good scare I hope you bros
enjoyed watching I'm gonna see if I can
try to play more music uh stories for
now because I really noticed that you
bros really want it and I want to give
you both stuff that you want to see so
anyway back in favor if you enjoyed
suggest me another custom story that is
really scary in the comments and I'd
really appreciate it
it's tails and pressing my iPhone and
then 90 degrees flex during the night as
my name